okay so i haven't decided yet but if i
end up having this
in the thumbnail of this video don't
judge too harshly it just
makes sense to me right now
[Music]
the queen's gambit so the queen's
gambit's on netflix right now it's
mini series i guess i mean that's what
it is he's gonna call it a series and
i'm pretty sure it's over so it's a mini
series it starts anya taylor joy who
plays a girl named beth harmon she grows
up in this orphanage
and she learns very young that she has
an affinity and a natural talent for
chess so she grows up and this is her
quest over the years to hopefully become
the best chess player in the world
that's right queen's gambit's not a
period piece starring kate blanchett no
it's a chess move
so this is a chess movie or series minis
if i keep calling it a movie
in this video it's you know what i mean
so i don't know what to gush about first
anya taylor joy being great in the
series
or chess itself but if you're gonna
permit me a couple minutes let me gush
about chess
chess is quite simply an amazing game in
fact i think it's the only game i
consider the perfect game and what is
perfect that's a pretty subjective term
but
for me in the context of this and the
context of talking about chess
it has to do with the contrast between
how simple and accessible a game
is to how infinitely complex the battles
can be when playing that game
and to me that's chess it's a game that
requires no patches no dlc no expansions
unless you're counting star trek the
next generation 3d chess and whenever
i'm playing an rts or a tabletop game i
just see the dna of chess
i was never like a chess expert in life
but i always
loved the game i love the feeling that
at a point you feel like you're in the
last scene in reservoir dogs you feel
like tony stark in avengers infinity
war let's do it you shoot my guy and
i'll blast him let's go
that is chess all right so that's my
love for the game of chess so now that
brings me to talking about this mini
series which is a mini series
worth loving first of all anya taylor
joy she carries the entire thing she is
great we know she's great she's shown
time and time again
that she is in fact a great actor and
when i say she carries this entire thing
she absolutely
positively does that has to do with how
she portrays the character
and how her character is written i
thought her character is amazing because
she has this
natural talent for chess it's neat
seeing her
mentally play the entire games on the
ceiling with the shadows she's one of
those prodigies you know
she can play an entire game of chess in
her head but there's still growth with
her character whether it be
emotional growth whether it be life
growth and
growth in her game the point is i like
the fact that the queen's gambit shows
that
natural talent that'll get you so far
but you still need
chubs to come in there and help you with
your putting game i mean she loses that
first loss
it hurts because she's like no i'm i'm
so good but she learns her natural
talent
in this world of competitive chess play
that's not necessarily going to be
enough and we all know how that is you
know that when you're really good at
something when you really take a hit
you have that loss it stings she wins
and loses enough to where it's like it
just
makes it feel real and tangible like
she's an accessible human being we can
all relate to because
we've all lost a lot in life right and
we will continue to do so
throughout life until the end i just
appreciate the fact the show hammers
home the point that
winning and losing both important so i
like that growth i like
her personal growth as well whether it
be with her and her adoptive mom which
at first i was like oh the mom's one of
those moms that's there for the money
but
you do feel the love there there is a
mother-daughter relationship so i like
the fact that the show expands on that
but
really it's her character's arc you
really feel like she
grows matures and she really comes into
her own i thought the series was an
interesting chess quest but also an
amazing coming-of-age story
i like the supporting characters too
this mini series takes place over
a span of years so supporting characters
they grow too
seeing growth among them among her
between them and her
benny i loved benny benny's one of those
dudes like a lot of people they're like
okay
the chess game starts when we sit down
he was like no no the chess game starts
when we all enter the room i'm getting
their heads first and i'm gonna that'll
give me the edge he knew
he knew when the game actually starts
and he actually taught me an important
thing because i want to talk about how
rad i thought benny was i was like wait
a minute let me look
into the guy because i'm going to find
out he i don't know
did something and people in the comment
section would be like oh he's actually a
dick in real life
and he taught me a very important thing
this is not based on a true story
i thought it was for like half of it
nope it's not completely fictional it
doesn't make it any less engaging it
just
surprised me it's executed in such a way
where you would swear
it's real and i guess that is a
testament to the production of the
series i know maybe if it was real it'd
be
a lot less interesting who knows maybe
the world of
competitive chess play just isn't that
dramatic but if you're talking about
production the production of this series
like
it you know when it takes place i mean
it tells you what year it takes place
and i guess that's helpful to go down to
the year to be like okay
this is 1968. i need to know the exact
year but you know it's the 60s you know
from the production design
and the music the soundtrack great stuff
it's what i love about forrest gump you
know the decade that takes place
from the soundtrack and forrest gump is
my favorite
soundtrack of all time in terms of
collection of rock music but queen's
gambit
had some great one of the things i love
about this mini series is it's not
just a peek behind the curtain you
really feel like you have a backstage
pass into this world of competitive
chess play
you don't just get a peek you get
brought into this world that you
otherwise
would not have ever been brought into
and you get to
live this experience vicariously through
the character it's worth noting here
that the queen's gambit pulls that off
because not everything that tries that
pulls it off like social network did you
know it was this world of
creating facebook and this social
network and
magic mike did the world of mail
strippers
didn't know i gave a [ __ ] but i watched
magic mike and i was like that was
interesting and the queen's gambit does
and granted it's a game i already
actually did give a [ __ ] about you
really feel like you're there and
you want to know as much about it you
want to love this game as much as she
does and really
you have this feeling throughout this
ride of it being a rock star
story between the drinking substance
abuse the spiral out of control and the
natural talent of her being a badass it
does have the beats of it being a rock
star story
just without her being a musician it's a
well-written story with well-written
characters
with great actors portraying them
interesting premise interesting ride the
only
things that i have to say about it in
terms of the negative
sometimes passage of time you're like
okay it's been this many years i gotta
clock that it doesn't feel like it's
been that many years but it has and the
very
end chess matches i mean when she's
there and this is it
like i love the tone of the room but i
could have gone for
watching more of the chess matches like
i feel like i watched and saw more
of the earlier chess matches than i did
at the
pinnacle like these are the chess
matches of chess matches i felt like i
wanted to see more i'm sure if i
side by side them and clock them it's
probably equal time regardless i could
have gone for seeing more of the endgame
chess matches but it's worth watching on
netflix if you have netflix check it out
i binged it in a day
so the queen's gambit have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]